ich war damals s1 ist zwar ist 35 im
stab des jäger partie 14 dienstgrad
leutnant am 21 august als der einmarsch
der russischen truppen erfolgte war ich
nicht in der garnison sondern auf
bergführer gehilfen kurs es wurde damals
beim kurs beraten ob der kurs
abgebrochen werden sollte nein es wurden
einzelne personen darunter ich rück
gerufen
als ich zurückkam darf ich meine passion
in einem verfügungsrahmen watts
unterkunft in wolkersdorf an das partien
hatte den auftrag hat die brünner straße
im ernstfall zu sperren
ich bin aber keine technischen
vorbereitungen getroffen werden weil es
war kein offizieller einsatz sondern
eine verstärkung der grenzgang sonnen
und wir waren das ja behindert durch
wild seine und betretungsverbote die
stimmung war sehr schlecht weil die
bevölkerung uns wirklich nicht sehr
ernst nahmen sie fragte was wir da weit
hinter der grenze überhaupt tun und
warum wir hier sozusagen jetzt in der
etappe herumkurven die maßnahmen die ich
getroffen habe war einmal die erkundung
der sperre der bundesstraße 7 noch zu
intensivieren und mit hilfe eines
offiziers der über baumaschinen verfügte
man wolkersdorf trafen wir alle vorbei
jungen wenn es zu einem übergriff
gekommen wäre wenn innerhalb kurzer zeit
zumindestens regel stellungen an der
bundesstraße im haus gebaut worden
eines tages erschien überraschend der
bundesminister es kam schon ein treffen
an der bundesstraße 7 und mein patrons
kommunen stellte die denkwürdige frage
an herrn bundesminister der herr
bundesminister sie kann sich von früher
was machen wir wenn die russen wirklich
kommen und die erstaunliche antwort ich
capture pro user und dann hat so für
mich als jungen reitern die etwas mehr
an taktischen in vielen erwartet hätte
also etwas überraschen